what is a man is he truly the greatest
of God's creations or just another
Neutron bouncing off of other neutrons
Wyant Disneyland or Chippendale the
exact same height as goofy and Mickey
what is the purpose of calling a baker's
dozen a baker's dozen why don't they
just make up a new word for it like
pumpy frugal and whatever happened to my
Beetlejuice lunchbox
why haven't they invented a show called
the zombie babies dandelions may be
dandy but how the hell are they lions
if wily coyote can order these
inventions from the Acme corporation why
doesn't he just order a goddamn pizza
what if the person whose face was big
stuff was just born that way since the
Wicked Witch of the West can die with
water is brought on her does that mean
that she never takes a shower or sweats
maybe that's why she's so cranky
what if professional wrestlers really do
wrestle when they get in the ring and
all that footage of them practicing
their lines behind the scenes what if
that's bacon why is it superheroes who
villains all over the world want to kill
always dress like brightly colored
bull's-eyes and whatever happened to my
Beetlejuice lunchbox what if the end of
the world is just a insulated graphic
says you ran out of quarters if the FBI
is so secretive then why have I heard of
them has anyone ever eject the American
Eagles ID
what if he's a liar how is it
autocorrect actually makes more mistakes
than it does things
if the nihilist believes in nothing that
how can the nile is believe in nihilism
and what the hell ever happened to might
Beetlejuice lunchbox if a millionaire
owns millions then why aren't poorer
people called dollar bears has anyone
ever thought about what Donald Duck
might taste like or am I just really
sick how come nobody has ever sculpted a
sculpture of a rock what is the purpose
of the top button in front of a shirt
fuck that but I'll just go without a
time in fact book ties what purpose do
they serve anyway is there ever a
situation where a tie is going to save
the day and what the fuck ever happened
to my Beetlejuice lunch Bob oh this
might Beetlejuice lunchbox